[Musique]
c'est en train de vous parler d'une
corporation dont l'extrême majorité des
policiers des membres sont en stress
post traumatique depuis cinq ans qui ont
parfois des comportements qui peuvent
s'apparenter à ce que certaines
associations observatrice des forces de
l'ordre disent qu'elle est le syndrome
de la citadelle assiégée d'où venez vous
madame roux à des policiers qui en
avaient pris leur leur revolver pour
leur tirer dessus et bien excuses non ça
n'excuse pas mais ça peut aller tic la
peur la peur dans lequel ils agissent
aujourd'hui
or la peur madame roux on le sait tout
le monde le sait est mauvaise
conseillère
vous avez aujourd'hui les policiers et
des gendarmes et particulièrement des
policiers dans les grandes
agglomérations qui ont le sentiment
d'être attaquée de toutes parts et qui
parfois perdu discernement monsieur
darmanin fait un texte email feu parce
que ce texte à vocation à démontrer que
il soutient les policiers et quelques
heures plus tard
eh bien il les lâche collectivement
alors même que encore une fois cette
manifestation les policiers ont été
victimes de violences et qu'il
s'agissait à l'évidence d'une
provocation d'extrême-gauche
j'ai l'impression que monsieur darmana
c'est un peu grisé de ce succès de
communication aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit
qu'en réalité il n'ya pas grand chose
regardez les dernières manifestations
qu'on a eu les mêmes blacks blocks kick
ass qui dénaturent les mouvements
sociaux qui ont dénaturé le mouvement
des gilets jaunes et bien sont toujours
là je ne suis pas et je ne serai pas de
ceux qui flatte les policiers quand ça
les arrange et qu'il est lâche quand ça
les arrange plus au gré des faits des
polémiques médiatiques à ceux comme
aurait pu le dire ma grand mère cette
phrase n'est pas d'elle être dans le
vent et le plaisir d'une feuille morte
article je vais vous faire écouter une
bande son qui dure dix secondes qui a
été publié non pas sur insiste d'extrême
gauche mais sur un média mainstream à
une heure de grande écoute samedi
quelques secondes après qu'on ait
constaté qu'un policier ait été lynché
et j'aimerais juste qu'on écoute ce qui
ce qui soit dit à ce moment là
l'article 24 du projet de loi sécurité
globale il prévoit de restreindre la
possibilité de filmer les forces de
l'ordre
article merci l'ennemi de l'intérieur
son travail premier c'est d'être devant
les femmes et les hommes qui servent le
ministère de l'intérieur quand ça va
bien et quand ça va moins bien
un article liberticide pour de nombreux
manifestants à l'article
liberticide pour de nombreux
manifestants
évidemment ce que nous avons tous pu
constater dans les témoignages et des
réactions recueillies dans les
manifestations samedi est un camouflet
pour le gouvernement pour le président
de la république et se camoufler ligne
est tout simplement à l'amateurisme
politique dans lequel on est depuis
quelques semaines linda kebab doit
peut-être aussi constaté qu' il faut
bien vérifier ses sources
c'est un métier le métier de journalisme
pour écouter je crois que les français
s'apercevront que nous sommes gouvernés
vraiment par une bande de pieds nickelés
lorsqu'une telle incompréhension ne
cesse de s'intensifier sur un sujet
aussi fondamental
nous avons le devoir de nous interroger
collectivement
mesdames et messieurs dès cet après midi
nous ne remettons au travail proposée
pour proposer une nouvelle écriture
complète de ce dispositif
si la majorité se contente d'une
réécriture de l'article 24 sait qu'elle
n'aura ni compris le sens de ce que nous
disent on y compris le sens des
manifestations qui ont eu lieu ce
week-end
si on veut revenir vers des choses
raisonnables et bien ça commence par le
retirer purement et simplement
et l'on connaît depuis quelques minutes
le lauréat du fameux prix goncourt 2020
une édition très particulière puisque
l'annoncé a été faite par
visioconférence et non pas comme le veut
la tradition au restaurant chez drouant
à paris et c'est l'anomalie d'hervé le
tellier qui remporte ce titre vous vous
y attendiez un second cours
non pas du tout c'est un prix très
symbolique est appris unis le fait même
d'espérer la voix est vraiment en dehors
de la fin ce n'était pas du tout dans
mon projet